Một tháng 12, thứ tiết tại các hủ cuộc chiến cả nước có nhiều biến đậu,
ngôi giống suốt hiện tại nhiều nơi, người dân cần địa phòng các hiện tưởng thứ tiết cụ đoàn như lúc, sẽ phải gió dật mạnh.
Dự kiến trong xấu dự tối vi cơ lũ quét, sật lời đất,
xù lũi trên xường gió, suy ngọt tại các tình xin là, tính họ, lâu gái,
tuyên quan, tháng 1, các bằng, lặng xương, bắc ninh, thình hóa, nghỉ ăn.
Cánh báo các độ dùi gió thiên thái, xò lũ quét, sật lời đất,
xù lũn đất xò mười lũ hoặc xong trảy cấp 1, tại tháng 1, lâu gái,
cào bằng cấp 2, phút họ, tuyên quan cấp 3, theo chung tâm dự báo khi tự thị văn Quốc xa,
tương ngay mùa một đĩnh nghệ 1, 2 tháng 1, lũ trên xong lũ, tuyên quan, xong cầu, xong tương, bắc ninh, xong thái mình,
hải phòng, tí tục lên, hà lưu xong là, giờ đậu ở nước đình.
Trong đật lũ này, định lũ trên các xong nỏ ở nước báo động 2 báo động 3 và trên báo động 3,
đỉnh lũ trên xong lũ, xong cầu, xong tương lên mức báo động 3 và trên báo động 3,
hà lưu xong là, hà tính, xấp 4 mức báo động 2.
Đi càng theo là tình trạm và đủ dự báo sĩnh ra tại các phụ chúng thúc phần xong,
các khu đồ thị thục hút vực bắc bộ, tưu thình hoa đến hà tính,
đồng này, lũ quét và sật lời đất trên các sởn giốc ở hút vực phụng lũi bắc bộ,
tưu thình hoa đến hà tính.